hello Tech Wizards and digital explorers
welcome to a journey into the core of
Linux the operating system powering over
2.3% of desktop computers globally and
is staggering 96.3% of the world's top 1
million servers I'm abisa and today we
are deling into one of the most vital
components of Linux its file systems
imagine a world where every piece of
digital information is meticulously
organized where every bite of data has
its own unique place that world exists
right inside your Linux machine so
buckle up as we dive deep into the
intricate Maze of Linux file systems
exploring how they work why they are
important and what makes them so unique
in the realm of operating systems in the
realm of Linux file systems like ext4
xfs and btrfs aren just names they are
sophisticated architectures that manage
how billions of bytes of data are stored
accessed and organized these systems are
the unsung heroes ensuring data
integrity and efficiency in our digital
world today we will uncover how these
file systems support everything from
your personal blogs to the largest data
centers hosting pedabytes of information
we will explore inot journaling mounting
and more terms that might sound complex
but are incredibly fascinating once you
get to know them and just a quick info
for you if you're an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through this course
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in top tier
product and security companies and
academicians from top universities this
course is designed to accommodate a
diverse range of Learners and this
course requires just a bachelor's degree
with a 50% average and no prior
programming experience and one plus year
of work experience is preferred if
you're passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and description box to find a cyber
security program that fits your
experience and areas of interest and now
Linux offers a diverse are of file
systems each tailored to specific
requirements and now let's explore some
prevalent Linux file systems so starting
with ex2 and then we have EX3 ext4 xfs
btrfs ZFS JFS and then we have Riser FS
so now starting with the first one that
is EXT2 so EXT2 extended file system 2
that is one of the Linux earliest and
most commonly used file systems EXT2 has
long been a default choice for many
Linux distributions it's known for its
stability and suitability for small to
mediumsized partitions
though it lacks a journaling feature
which can complicate file recovery post
crash now moving to the next file system
that is ext3 extended file system 3
building on EXT2 ext3 introduces
journaling to track file system changes
reducing data loss risk after crashes
it's a popular choice for its stability
reliability and performance and now move
to the next that is ext4 extended file
system 4 as the evolution of ext3 ext4
addresses some of its predecessors
limitations it supports larger files
quicker file system checks and enhanced
performance for larger disk features
like joural check summing also enhances
data Integrity ext4 is a default file
system in many modern Linux
distributions now moving to the next
file system that is xfs so xfs that is x
file system that is designed for large
scale storage and xfs excels in
performance and is suitable for file
systems up to 16 exabytes
it's a Top Choice for large data centers
offering scalability reliability and
featuring like Jing and file level
languages now moving on to the next file
system that is btrfs B3 file system a
newer Linux file system BFS supports
copy on write snapshots and sub volumes
allowing for multiple file systems
within a single partition it also
includes rate and compression support
btrfs is still under development and
isn't as commonly used as other file
systems next we have is ZFS ZFS zetabyte
file system initially developed for
Solaris ZFS is a robust system with
features like snapshots data compression
duplication and built-in rate renowned
for its data integrity and self filling
capabilities ZFS is not typically
included in Linux distributions pe2
licensing but can be installed
separately now moving to the next file
system that is GFS GFS Journal file
system that is developed by by IBM JFS
is known for its performance and
reliability it offers Jing file level
compression and online resizing making
it a strong choice for high performance
systems and now the next one that is
resizer FS so targeted at high
performance Computing resizer FS
includes features like journaling file
level encryption and support for larger
files while known for its speed and
reliability it's less common compared to
other file systems listed here now
moving to key Linux file system
directories so the Linux operating
systems file management is predominantly
handled through directories commonly
known as folders these elements are
crucial in the Linux file system serving
not just as file holders but also as
organizational tools imagine directories
as virtual boxes each capable of storing
files and other directories directories
in Linux play a vital role in providing
an ordered hierarchical framework for
file Arrangement this hierarchy
commences at the root directory denoted
AS Slash and extends into various sub
directories this approach allows for a
logical and systematic organization of
complex systems enhancing the use of
file management and access so key Linux
file system directories each directory
in the Linux file system serves a
distinct purpose here are some of the
significant directories starting with
the number one that is root directory so
root directory is the highest level in
the Linux file system hierarchy all
other directories and files are nested
within this R now moving to the next
directory that is bin standing for
binaries this directory contains
essential command line utilities and
programs vital for basic system
management and then we have boot so here
lies the boot loader files and the Kel
images necessary for system startup and
then we have Dev this directory host
device files representing both physical
like printers and dis and virtual
devices like Terminals and then we have
Etc directory that is home to system
system configuration files these are
utilized by various applications and
services and then we have home directory
it houses individual users directories
providing personal space for file and
setting storage and then we have Library
directory this directory stores shared
Library files needed by System programs
next we have media directory am mounting
point for removable media such as USB
drives CDs and DVDs and then we have MNT
that is mounting directory that is used
for temporarily mounting file systems
like Network file systems or disk images
next we have OPD directory a location
for additional software packages that
are not part of the standard system and
then we have standard bin directory a
directory for system binaries and
administrative tools essential for
system upkeep and then we have user
directory that contains user level
programs libraries documentation and
shared data files so these were the
directories in Linux file distribution
system
and now here are the key Concepts in
file systems starting with journaling
file system so these systems maintain a
log refer to as Journal this log records
changes to files that are not yet
permanently saved on the disk this
feature is particularly useful for
recovering loss changes in the event of
a system failure and the next we have is
versioning file systems these systems
preserve earlier versions of files
essentially they save file copies based
on their previous States at specific
inter
offering a backup mechanism that could
be based on minute or hourly updates and
next we have index nodes an i note
symbolizes a file or diory detailing
attributes like size permissions
ownership and physical locations and now
we'll see the demo for the Linux file
distribution
system so for that we'll open the
terminal with control all
t
and
now first we'll see in which directory
we currently are in so we are in home
abisara
so first we'll move to the root
directory for that we'll write the
command CD space slash so now we have
moved to the root directory and here
we'll see what types directories we have
we have bin Dev boot Etc op run swap
file so now we'll move to the bin
directory so in bin directory it
contains binaries or essential
executable
files so these are the binaries and
executable files that we can use in the
terminal only so
now as I will show you there's a bin
and there's sbin also this is
sbin so now we'll move to the sbin
directory for that we'll write the
command CD
sbin and here we see the directories of
sbin so what does sbin contain it
contains system binaries like Mount or
delete and the user that are used by the
root user so these binaries can be used
by the root user only
and then we have other directories that
is
Library so to move to the library
directory we'll write the command CD Li
and now we'll see its
directories so what does it contains it
stores common libraries between bin and
S spin so many directories are stored in
the library directory
only so then we have another directory
that is user directory under the root
only so to move to that we'll write CD
user so it says
that so first we'll move back to the
root
diory and then we'll move to the user
directory so it says that no such file
or
directory is present here we'll just
check
I think it's USR for
user yeah it's USR so user directory is
named as
USR we'll move to the user directory and
to see the director inside user so these
are the directories in user so user has
its own bin and sbin directory and the
binaries here are non essential binaries
and there's a local directory under user
so it contains binaries that you can
combine manually so these are all
the directories under root and you can
go to other directories also as I have
shown you the diagram of all the
directories under user or under the root
that I have shown in the previous thing
so you can check it out so in conclusion
the Linux file system with its directory
structure is a Cornerstone of the
operating system it facilitates
efficient data management while
upholding system stability and security
Linux file system is characterized by
its hierarchical tree like structure
with the root directory at its apex
various file systems in Linux CER to
different needs each with its pros and
cons the Linux directory structure
encompasses an area of directories each
designated for specific function like
system binaries boot files device files
and user files and with that we have
come to the end of this tutorial hope
you guys found it informative and
helpful till then stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here